Good morning everyone. Welcome to the Q2 kickoff. Quick round-table before we get into it.
Morning Sara. Engineering side is set. Ready for the sprint structure discussion.
I've got the feature backlog ranked by user value. Should take maybe twenty minutes to work through.
Same here. I wanted to flag the sprint cadence question before we get too far in.
Good, let's start there. David, give me your take on two-week versus three-week sprints.
Two weeks. Tighter feedback loops. We catch drift before it compounds, and it keeps the team honest about scope.
Agreed. Three weeks is too long without a checkpoint at our stage. We'd be planning before we knew if last sprint even landed.
And bi-weekly aligns with our customer check-ins. We can actually show them real progress each time.
Good. Decision: two-week sprints, starting Monday the seventeenth.
What's first in the queue? I want engineering to start scoping immediately.
Auth and user management. It's the blocker for every other feature. Permissions, invite flows, none of it works without a user model.
I'd agree. We cannot test invite flows or role checks without auth in place. It's genuinely blocking.
Marc, is auth realistic as sprint one priority? I don't want to overcommit the team.
Yes. Login, logout, basic RBAC, Auth0 integration. Well-scoped for one sprint, two at most. David holds the backend while I spec the token model.
Agreed. Decision: auth and user management is our first feature. Sprints one and two.
Quick note on scope — I'm thinking three roles for now: admin, editor, viewer. Custom roles are a v2 conversation.
Three roles is exactly right. Don't overbuild RBAC. Every enterprise customer wants custom roles and we'll never satisfy all of them upfront.
Agreed on three roles. I'll write the backend schema this week. Extensible design so we can add granularity later without a migration nightmare.
Good. What's after auth in the roadmap queue?
Workflow builder is next — that's the core product. After that, the inbox and notification layer. I'll share the full ranked doc after this call.
I need the workflow builder spec before sprint three. That's where the real technical complexity lives.
Spec will be ready by end of sprint one. Functional requirements written before David's team needs to pick it up.
Last item: daily standup time. The team poll landed on nine-thirty — does that work for everyone?
Works for me. Before the deep-work block and gives me time to check overnight CI first.
Fine by me. Nine is too early when I'm reviewing PRs until late.
Nine-thirty it is. Daily standup, nine-thirty AM, starting Monday. Léa will send the invite.
On it. I'll also block the sprint review cadence — Fridays at end of sprint, same group.
Perfect. Two-week sprints, auth first, standup nine-thirty. Good session everyone.